Chị ở thôi, phần này nhạy lột thị, nó chỉ có rất là đủ tiền như này
Phó kỳ lột thịt như này
Lột thịt như này nó có bà được cái chiếm rất là phy tổng, cho nó có chiếm ở phy tổng, cho nó có bố nè
Thế có thịt rất là bà chập này nữa
Điệt bắt bộ, bà chập này
Bà chập này thì đây có chiếm là điều kiệ cận đủ luôn
Tại vì khi nó rất là bà chập này thì cái bây giờ ít quang khâu mong chắc là một nghiệp đơn rồi
Thì nó sẽ có đúng 2 nghiệp đơn, vài nó 2 cũng một khoảng ba
Nên chắc chắn nó nó phy dơ bà chập này
Bà bây giờ cái biến những một bài toán đơn giả hướng rất nhiều
Đây có tìm hơn sau cho ham số, em ý có chúng ta có lũng một điểm cực chị
Và đây là tất cả gì mà cho nó cận bệnh là mức quay cùng
Cái em cái tìm hơn